you know i just had like a mentally
transformative experience where a week
before junior year of college at
michigan my dad passed away suddenly he
passed away
from a stroke he was 49 years old he was
perfectly healthy and after that
experience everything just became
clearer around
one how most things that we worry about
on a daily basis in life are wildly
unimportant and two
how
your time on your uh life countdown
clock you have no idea when it's gonna
hit zero and basically i said to myself
if if i knew my countdown clock was
hitting zero tomorrow what would i
rather be doing with my time and it was
like a no-brainer it was like i knew
that i would hey friends and welcome
back to deep dive the ongoing podcast
where every week i sit down with authors
entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people and we talk about how
they got to where they are and the
strategies and tools that we can learn
that can help us apply to try and
hopefully live our best lives what
you're about to hear is a conversation
between me and alex lieberman the
co-founder and executive chairman of a
company called morning brew and morning
brews is like huge media company now but
it started off as an email newsletter
and we kind of dig into the story behind
that and interestingly alex sold morning
brew to business insider for around 75
million dollars a couple years ago at
the age of 28. so he made like tens of
millions of dollars at the age of 28
which is absolutely absurd and like
super inspiring and ridiculously
interesting because it's like hey how
the hell did you do that and b what the
hell do you do beyond that point when
you feel like you've made it in life and
so we talk a lot about kind of lessons
that we can learn from his journey
of building this business from day one
and so if you're if you've been thinking
of starting a business or growing a
business or kick starting a business or
anything like that you'll find a lot of
valuable stuff in there but then we also
talk about like kind of what it means to
find purpose in life and live life
beyond such a windfall and how alex is
kind of navigating some of these
challenges i got a bunch of value out of
this conversation i always loved talking
to alex and i've had a few zoom calls
over the years um and i'm very excited
for you guys to hear the conversation as
well so without further ado i hope you
enjoy this conversation between me and
alex lieberman alex thank you so much
for being on the deep dive how are you
doing today good man thanks so much for
having me
it's gonna be it's gonna be fun um i'd
love to get started so you've got a a
super interesting back story and i would
just like i i would love to start with a
question of
how how did we get here what was the
backstory of alex lieberman
yeah so
i am originally from new jersey uh and i
grew up in a finance family so everyone
in my family no matter where you looked
on my family tree
worked on wall street
my dad worked in sales and trading my
mom worked in sales and trading my
grandpa worked in sales and trading
and so
growing up uh you know
and having the value of you know family
is the most important thing
there was only one possible career in my
mind which was to work on wall street
like i really didn't think about
anything else
uh and so i went to a small private
school in new jersey it was great for
for some things wasn't great for other
things i loved it for the academics and
the athletics didn't love it for
uh the social part of the experience and
so i wanted a very different experience
in my college experience and so i ended
up going to the university of michigan
which was very
non-traditional from my high school
basically my high school i had 120
people in my graduating class a third of
the class went to ivy leagues
a third of the class went to what are
called nez cac schools like northeastern
schools like colgate middlebury uh and
then there was a third that were kind of
like the the degenerates in the class
that would go somewhere else and i was
one of those people i went to
the university of michigan um
loved my experience there i was in the
business program and i was kind of on
the path uh up to that point i was on
the path to work on wall street because
that was my goal and so i did
internships after each year in college i
was in the business program
and i got into my senior year
at michigan
and the way it works uh you know in the
states with internships is you have a uh
your internship after your junior year
in finance and if you do well in that
internship you get an offer and so then
in your senior year in your last year of
college you don't have to recruit for
jobs you already have that job for when
you leave school and so that that's what
happened for me i had my internship at
morgan stanley working in sales and
trading junior year i got an offer back
and so i accepted that offer i got into
my senior year at michigan i didn't have
to recruit for a job i only had to take
three classes my entire senior year
because i had completed my credits and
so i got into the year and i was
basically like okay this is gonna be fun
i'll play a lot of video games but i
should probably do something else in
order to keep my brain sharp for when i
graduate and go you know work in finance
and so i i started helping students
prepare for job interviews and one of
the ways that i would help them is i
would do my a mock interview with them
that was something my dad always did
with me when i was prepping for
interviews is he would mock interview me
as as if we he was an interviewer and
one question i would always ask students
is how do you keep up with the business
world to me this was like the layup
question just to get them comfortable
not be nervous and every student
basically said the same thing which was
i read the wall street journal uh it's
what my parents told me to do but it's a
bit dense it's a bit dry
and
that
just really resonated with me because i
was like this is crazy these students
are about to spend
50 percent of their life of their waking
hours between the ages of
21 and let's call it 70 working in
business
and they read business news because they
feel like they have to because their
parents told them to like it sounded
crazy
it started so i started
writing a daily business roundup about
the business world that in the beginning
was really shitty like it was a really
bad product uh but it was good enough to
really catch people's eye and get their
interest
and sending out that first newsletter in
i believe it was october of 2014 so my
first semester senior year
was the start of what would be a seven
year journey of building morning brew
amazing okay i i that that was the point
where i wanted to zoom in on so there's
a lot of people that would that would
notice something that huh it's it's kind
of weird that all of these people
applying to all these jobs are like
reading business news but seeming to not
enjoy it what was it that made you take
that leap to therefore i'm going to
write my own email newsletter because
that's not a normal thing to think like
what was going on there yeah i mean it's
interesting because i was not thinking
about it as a business at all
the the interesting thing is like i've
never thought about myself as like an
entrepreneur or that i have to build a
business but i've always been a tinkerer
like i've always just like tried doing
random things and i i started writing
that newsletter which by the way at the
time wasn't called morning brew it was
called market corner uh and i'll
describe what that product looked like
in the beginning because again it was
pretty
mediocre but basically i wrote it
because one
selfishly i wanted to keep up to date
with what was happening in the business
world so that when i left college and i
went into my job in finance i felt like
my brain was on top of things and so the
process
of reading what was going on in business
and distilling it into these bite-sized
chunks was almost like a forced function
for me staying on top of my game then
the second part i would say was more
selfless which was i just wanted to help
these students keep up to date with the
business world and to me the way to do
it was just to start writing this thing
and i had an abundance of time how did
you have an abundance of time
yeah so
as you know as i had mentioned basically
i got into my senior year i had already
gotten my job so i had that junior year
internship and
i got an offer to work full-time
at so now you're it's like you're
coasting the rest of the year yeah
exactly basically my fourth year of
college my senior year i was coasting i
didn't have to recruit for a job i only
had to take three classes
and so i only really had to spend
two hours any given day throughout
senior year of college actually spent on
academics in college and i spent i had
to spend zero amount of time on jobs and
so that left you know however many
waking hours uh
14 waking hours a day to do something
with my time and this was one of the
things that i decided to do with my time
uh did you try and do anything else with
your time i'm curious to stay here any
other experiments running in the
background
uh
nothing that was uh as i would say
productive as this i probably spent
three or four hours a day working on uh
market corner market corner which would
then turn into morning brew i did spen i
spent a lot of time playing video games
such as i played a lot of fifa nhl uh
and call of duty
i also in my senior year tried to
experience
a lot of just extracurriculars
at michigan so i went to like sports
events that i never thought of going to
like i went to
uh the university of michigan gymnastics
meet i went to the soccer
games just because
i kind of thought to myself this is the
last year that i'm really going to be
able to experience this amazing
university as a student i might as well
just like make the most of it and then i
was a teaching assistant my senior year
i uh was a ta for a real estate class
which was actually my favorite class
it was um
it was a interdisciplinary grad level
real estate class where basically
the class was not lectures it was you
were tasked
with picking an actual physical location
in the us
where you thought there was an
opportunity to buy the location like buy
the real estate develop a property and
turn it into a residential retail
commercial like a multi-use property
and it was an interdisciplinary group so
where it was a business student it was
an architecture student it was a legal
student and it was an urban planning
student and so the four of us literally
spent a semester where we went to parts
of michigan and we
drew up our plan for developing like a
full-blown
you know 250 000 square foot property
the architect literally drew out the
exact specs of the property the urban
planner wrote up the documents that you
would use to apply to the city i worked
on the financials and the legal uh
student uh basically
shared what the pipeline was of
contracts that we would have to figure
out for the property so that was one
other thing i did senior year
so you said
that sounds super cool uh and you said
this class was your favorite i wonder
like what did you learn from this class
that maybe you've applied applied later
in life yeah i mean this is the
interesting thing i
loved my experience at michigan but if
you were to ask me
why i loved it i would not say it was
for the academics because i would say
there's maybe two classes in the
entirety of
my education at michigan that i feel
like i've actually applied in my career
and i think this just speaks to where a
lot of academia is broken
and i think it's broken for a lot of
reasons i think uh it's broken because
it teaches you what to think versus how
to think i think it's broken because
a lot of people are lifelong academics
and that's not inherently bad but i wish
there was more attraction to
entrepreneurs and practitioners going
back to universities because i think it
would make what you learn far more
applicable because it's being taught by
people that actually did the thing i
loved this class because it was one of
the two classes where i actually felt
like this is simulating what i'm going
to be dealing with in real life it is a
real life project that i could see
myself doing this in the future if i
wanted to you know invest in real estate
this is something i would go through and
it was interdisciplinary in nature which
is inherently
all of your experience in your career
and life is working with people that
have diversity of thought and experience
from you
nice so this real estate was class
number one what was class number two
that actually taught you something
my excel class it was the class yeah
yeah okay it was my class that uh
basically taught us how to
uh do
pivot tables uh visual basic shortcuts
in excel
and for me like excel
is a program that i probably will use my
entire life with different levels of
kind of intensity or frequency when i
was working in finance before i went
full-time on morning brew i used excel a
lot like i was doing a lot of just
modeling and calculations in excel today
i would say i use it maybe once or twice
a week but having that proficiency in
excel it's kind of like i would consider
it kind of the the timeless skill in the
same way that i would say actually the
most valuable class i've ever taken my
life was my fourth grade typing class
like i i've used this skill more than
any other skill in life and i've talked
to people who didn't take typing and i
can see the impact that it's had on them
and so yeah i just view excel as a
timeless skill just like i have you
typing on my computer as a timeless
skill
interesting so a few thoughts on this
yeah firstly so um my brother is working
on a startup to try and um compete with
excel really
yeah it's called causal um they're
trying to basically be the new xl but
for um number crunching because
excellent has all these different
excellent has all these different use
cases and it's it's a very general tool
but you'll you'll get like
ridiculous you know trillion dollar
companies using excel to manage their
forecasting and you'll also get people
using it to figure out the scores in
their five-a-side football league and
yeah their kids kids football practice
and
their sort of uh their thesis is that
uncertainty calculations and modeling
and stuff is really hard to do in excel
where you have like loads of uncertainty
with all these different numbers
plugging in it's really hard when you
when an excel sheet gets really big for
anyone other than the person who made it
to understand what's going on and even
then that person probably doesn't
understand what's going on and so it's
really hard to kind of change your
assumptions and all this all this stuff
so they're building building uh i see it
right now i looked it up causal app
causal replaces your spreadsheets with a
better way to build models connect to
data and share dashboards with your team
your brother sounds very smart um oh
they they they raised 4.2 million in
2021. uh this is awesome uh yeah i can
also read more about it recently oh
really you should look into that start
using um i was gonna say now now you
have to get ultimately that if they get
big enough you have to get them to work
with uh universities so universities
teach causal courses
oh my goodness that's a great idea yeah
yeah good for you know any kind of
number crunching and modeling and stuff
yeah um i also very much agree on on the
typing front so
you know i've put in large amounts of
time and effort into actually just
practicing my typing once in a while
through typing tests and stuff oh i've
seen the video yeah whatever the speed
was it was is absolutely ridiculous i
remember watching that video and then
doing a typing test and just feeling
horrible about myself after doing that
test
what was the speed again
i think it was one 156 words per minute
that's my record i need to try and bump
that up but it's it's it's kind of weird
so these last few days i've been on this
team retreat in wales currently
overlooking the hills it's very nice um
but i sort of set myself the challenge
that every day i was going to write a
whole first draft chapter of my book
each day each day it's sort of been like
sort of five six there's seven thousand
words
and it's just kind of
i think have you done it
yeah so every time the last few days
i've been banging out one chapter and i
need to do another one today but i've
already done four thousand words in
about a one and a half hour slot this
morning and it's like amazing that i i
think previously when my typing speed
was half or a third what it currently is
it's like
it would be a bit of a bottleneck like
my brain would think faster than i'd be
able to type yeah but the faster my
typing speed is gone it's like i can
type at the speed of thought almost and
so it's almost so easy or so easy to if
i've got something in my head to
translate it into words on a page and
it's it's you know it's really bad
obviously but like you know the first
draft of anything is really crap so
that's what my editor keeps on saying
just like spew out all the stuff you've
got in your head onto the page like
and then we'll we'll clean it up in post
so so honestly that was something i'm
very interested about because
if i remember correctly like i remember
the general um you know the general gist
of the book that you're writing and
when i've thought about writing books
the thing that's always kind of been
like the bottleneck in my head is will i
be able to just write chapters from my
head or am i going to have to like be
referencing
uh resources online or references but if
i do that is that going to distract me
because now i'm plugged into technology
so when you're writing these chapters a
day are you fully disconnected from the
internet and you're just writing five
thousand to seven thousand words of
whatever comes to your mind
um great question yeah so i was i was
worried about this as well um uh i i'm
connected to the internet because i use
it go to a lot of google docs which is
annoying for offline stuff but if i ever
get to a place where
i need research or something like that
i'll just do a little apparently all
writers do this tk
um you just write tk need research about
xyz over here um you know yesterday i
was working on a chapter where i was
talking about kind of feelings of
anxiety and self-doubt when it comes to
procrastination
and
i knew i wanted a line that sort of
described the feeling of anxiety but i
couldn't be bothered to sit down and
figure out oh crap how to describe the
feeling of anxiety so i just wrote uh
anxiety is that feeling of tk xyz
and then me or the editor will come back
to it later and it just sort of keeps me
in the flow yeah so you just give
yourself the permission to like leave
space and revisit the things that you do
need to do more research later on which
by the way
we should talk about this at some point
in the conversation about
uh the feelings of anxiety related to
procrastination because i would actually
argue that is one of the biggest things
in my life that creates self-doubt lack
of self-belief it stems from feeling
like i'm a chronic procrastinator in
life and i have been since freshman year
of college okay that's okay we'll do
we'll we'll put a bookmark on that and
definitely come back to it because i
imagine people would find that
surprising given
kind of your your story um yeah so
definitely bookmark in there i was going
to ask as well so other than typing and
excel have you ever have you found any
other sort of
meta skills that are generally useful
for life yes but they weren't taught in
university uh so one is storytelling and
selling
like i think the number one skill
that helped me be a strong founder
especially in the early days of building
our business is the ability to sell and
i think i'm blessed in the sense that
that's just one of my intuitive
superpowers it's something my dad worked
on with me as i was growing up he was
really
focused on my ability to articulate uh
he thought that was really important
i ended up taking
a business communications class at
michigan but to be totally honest i
didn't find it very valuable half the
time was spent doing kind of public
speaking half the time was spent
literally like digital communication
like how to write an email and i found
that to to be tough tough as in like not
helpful but yeah i mean sales i would
say is that if you are trying to elevate
yourself as a professional in any way
not just as an entrepreneur just in your
career you find yourself selling
yourself
far more times than you realize so like
just even talking about a business when
we were starting morning brew we're
talking about a startup that was a media
company media companies are generally
not
venture backable so you can't raise from
institutions
uh we had a newsletter that's all we had
we had 30 000 subscribers at the time we
weren't making any money but we had to
raise money in order to possibly get to
a place of making money and so
selling investors on why
a 21 year old and a 19 year old who have
a media company where media companies
are generally not profitable businesses
and we weren't making money yet and by
the way it's not really a media company
it's a newsletter we had to sell them on
why they should
put their hard-earned money in our
business
we had to sell our initial employees on
why they should leave their steady jobs
to join a business that's making zero
dollars and we had to sell advertisers
because that was the first way we made
money as a business we had to sell
advertisers like
discover card large financial
institutions on why they should even
bother wasting their time on a company
that reaches 30 000 people versus
allocating that time to thinking about
say a television commercial that reads
reaches millions of people
and so i'd say that is
the number one meta skill i'd actually
argue it's a meta skill even like in
personal life not just professional life
i've i've heard a lot of people say that
that you know
the the skill of selling is kind of yeah
is well one of the one of the most
useful skills you can have but i've
always kind of wondered and i never
quite followed this thought of like what
does what does that actually mean
like i wouldn't say i'm good at selling
but i've i guess i have sold stuff in
the past and i just don't really think
of selling as like a thing
you sell yourself on youtube every time
you post a video like and this is
actually an interesting thing of and
i've thought a lot about this is
what's the difference between sales and
or selling and storytelling
and my view is just if something comes
off as selling it's just shitty
storytelling
uh and and
and so my view is like why do people
watch your videos for a long time why
did you just hit three million
subscribers on youtube when there's a
bunch an abundance of content because
you're not the first person to talk
about topics related to productivity to
bettering yourself right you have found
a way to storytell
in a way that captivates people and
keeps them engaged so you are
innately good at storytelling i just
don't think i think it is quite natural
and intuitive to you it doesn't feel
like work to script and then
uh deliver that in front of a camera you
couldn't be where you are today without
being exceptional at storytelling how do
people get better at this it's a great
question um my answer would be it's a
combination of practice
of
shadowing and feedback and of
understanding the fundamentals of what
it means to story tell well
so going in reverse order
i think
that there there are tried and true
there's the science to it there's like
tried and true formulas for what is a
captivating story for people uh and so
like for example i'm reading uh the book
creativity inc right now which is the
story of pixar like are there are story
arcs which is like there is a hero the
hero is on a journey the hero on the
journey experiences a challenge uh in
experiencing the the challenge they go
through adversity they overcome the
challenge and they
reach their goal like that is one story
arc i think there are a number of
formulas this way so at base level i
think
studying the best storytellers of all
time uh and studying the formulas that
they use to tell stories is the first
step the second step is what i would say
is
the combination of practice and
shadowing and so the example i'll use
for you is in the early days of morning
brew when we had to pitch advertisers on
advertising in our newsletter i had
never sold
in a professional setting anything
before
but i had to do it there was no option
we had to make money
and so i
you know got reps
pitching probably in our first year 250
advertisers on 30-minute calls about who
morning brew was what we stood for and
why spending your money with us was
worth your time and your money
based on what your goals were and the
first pitch i did probably the second
pitch probably the 20th pitch i did was
really bad but every time i would take
five to ten minutes after a pitch and
i'd have a reflection period where i
would
write down what are the things that i
think i did well and what is one thing i
would change for the next pitch i do and
i would record every pitch i did as well
so
then thinking about shadowing and
feedback right i was delivering feedback
for myself but a big thing that i did
with our junior sales people when they
joined morning brew
was when they would do a pitch in the
early days i would join them on those
calls so that first of all like i would
do the sales pitch they would listen to
me so they would sponge up that
information we would do that for a few
weeks and then gradually i would hand
off the reigns to them where they would
start doing the pitch
we would record it we would listen back
to it together after which by the way
for anyone who hasn't listened to their
voice before and hasn't listened to
themselves do a sales pitch it is going
to be excruciating for you to do the
first time but it is so valuable
i would give them feedback and then they
would
use that feedback the next time and you
know you look at a company like
gong
gong is a multi-billion dollar sales
software company there's a reason it's
such a valuable business so what gog
basically allows you to do is allow
sales orgs to record every sales call
they have and then in in a database
holds all of the sales calls organized
by who the seller was the type of client
that it was and it also will do things
as sophisticated as say what percentage
of the time on the call were you talking
versus what percentage of the time was
the person talking and it will
categorize what were you talking about
almost like you know on youtube how you
can kind of set the chapters of an
episode it does that automatically in
your sales call and so then any seller
can go on to gong and study what are
quote unquote the best calls that have
led to
the conversations that convert their
clients the end of the day there is the
there is this art and science to
understanding what works for you to
storytell in a way that leverages your
strengths um
but also
understanding the science of what works
well and what are kind of like the the
the natural story arcs that people over
the course of time are always attracted
to
nice that's a that's a great answer
was that off the cuff or have you have
you ever thought about this before that
that was off the cuff yeah yeah that was
good that was like framework i love it
it was like very meta we were using a
storytelling framework and talking about
storytelling framework 100
alrighty little interlude to tell you a
little bit about this book the e-myth
revisited which is a book that both me
and alex absolutely swear by in terms of
it just being super helpful in building
businesses it's about why most small
businesses don't work and what to do
about it by michael gerber now this is a
book that i usually recommend for
basically anyone who wants to scale up
their business but if you don't have
time to read the book and i do recommend
you do actually read it you can check
out a summary of the book over a short
form who are very kindly sponsoring this
episode of the podcast if you haven't
heard by now short form is the absolute
best service that summarizes books they
just have sick book summaries and
they're way more than just book
summaries they're like include one page
summaries of the book just in a single
page but they also include chapter by
chapter summaries of each of the
chapters and they also include these
like interactive exercises in between
some of the sections so you can really
engage with the points and even better
they also kind of regard books as being
you know with a little bit more critical
appraisal kind of vibes than a lot of
other book summary services do so if for
example in the book michael gerber makes
a point which is particularly
controversial or which another author
might disagree with then they'll add a
little short form note that says hey
this point was a bit controversial like
maybe you should check out this other
book that argues for the exact opposite
and that's just really good in terms of
just getting a balanced viewpoint on the
stuff that we read there's two main ways
that i personally use short form the
first one is when if i get a new book
recommendation and i don't necessarily
want to read the book directly or i'm
not 100 sold on reading the book then
i'll often go on short form on my phone
or my laptop and be like hey has short
form got a summary of the book usually
they do if it's the sort of nonfiction
that i enjoy reading and then i'll often
read the book summary first and if i
like the book summary then i may or may
not decide to read the book itself and
secondly i use short form as a way of
revisiting my highlights from books so
for example i've only read the e myth
revisited once but i've actually read
the short form summary of it about three
times uh once in preparation for my
part-time creatorpreneur course but also
twice just randomly because i was like
this has been a really good book i first
read it in 2019 changed my life i don't
want to reread it because it's like i've
got most of the value but let me just
revisit the points so something like
short form is super helpful for that if
any of that sounds up your straight then
head over to short form dot com forward
slash deep dive and with that url you
will get 20 off the annual premium
subscription and you'll get access to
the best service that summarizes books
in the world okay so it's march 2015 you
launch morning brew as a proper
newsletter with a proper website that
people can actually sign up for
what happens next we become obsessed
with two things how do we make this
newsletter as good as humanly possible
and how do we grow it as quickly as
possible and so
i would say we did kind of some pretty
creative things to make the newsletter
really good in the early days i'd say
the first thing was austin and i said to
ourselves like we can help write this
thing but we need more support
and so we had reached out in our
newsletter
to
students who are reading our newsletter
and we said hey if you're interested in
writing about business and you want to
get your words in front of hundreds or
thousands of people we'd love you to
come right for the brew and so we ended
up having a rotation
of probably eight writers at any given
time from different universities who
were writing call two stories a week in
our newsletter
so that was kind of like our our uh
newsroom of sorts
and these writers were not paid they
were just doing it because they wanted
to
get their brand and their words into the
world and they they were
excited about what morning brew was and
what it represented then we found an
editor
and that editor was someone who was in
the business school with us at michigan
so he's very into markets and he still
works in finance today but he also wrote
for michigan's newspaper so he had
really strong editing chops so he was
the guy who basically set the content
schedule for those six to eight college
students and then he would edit their
first drafts
then this the third thing we did is kind
of the i would say the the least
traditional
from the beginning austin and i said our
content needs to read like you're having
a conversation with your smart and
sociable best friend it can't read like
traditional business news where it feels
like a robot is throwing up words on you
yeah and so we're like what is gonna
give our
our
uh
content
that x factor that's gonna feel
quick-witted and smart and funny
and so we're like we need to find a
funny person
and so we
we put out we put it out a uh you know a
job post for a funny person and we found
our funny person and our funny person
was this guy grant he was in a program
called organizational studies at
michigan which was quasi business
schools like similar to the business
school less focused on finance and more
focused on like uh organizational
organization building culture et cetera
so he was in that program but he was
also in the improv troupe
at michigan and so he was hilarious and
he was a good writer and understood
business and so we brought him on as
that literally the the the job we called
it was he was our voice editor so we had
our writers we had our uh editor and we
had our voice editor and that was the
process that we got to of putting out
our newsletter every day
and that gave austin and i more time to
grow the thing and so the way that we
thought about growing our thing was
the the visual i have is like a bicycle
so you have a bicycle and you have a hub
in the middle the metal hub and then you
have spokes that go out to the the the
wheel like the outside of the wheel of
the bicycle right so you have a hub and
you have spokes and our view was
spokes are all of the people that we
think should read morning brew so those
are college business students
hubs are the people that are basically
the people or the channels that have
access to all of these spokes how do we
get the attention of hubs so we don't
have to go to every spoke and convince
them to read our newsletter
and so at michigan what that looked like
was
teachers
and club presidents if we could get in
front of teachers classes we could get
in front of 75 to 500 students and if we
could get in front of club presidents we
could get into in front of say 50 to 250
students and so basically for all of our
second semester senior year at michigan
austin and i spent going back to the the
importance of storytelling and selling
we spent our whole second semester in
about
150 club meetings or or classes
pitching club uh students on why they
should read morning brew and so we'd go
into a class we would give our
two-minute uh appeal
about what boarding brew was why this
was the best business newsletter in the
world how it was free so there was no
downside you could sign up and if you
didn't like it you could unsubscribe no
hard feelings and then what we would do
is we'd pass around a sheet of paper
with a pen and we would ask students to
write down their email address we would
take that notepad after the class and we
would type in manually all of their
email addresses and the reason we passed
around a pad and a paper is because the
conversion rate of
people writing down their email on a pad
was significantly higher than us getting
in front of the class and saying pull
out your laptop go to morningbrew.com
and put in your email address because
there were far more steps it was pulling
out laptop opening laptop going to
safari or chrome putting in morning brew
putting an email address whatever that
is five or six steps whereas
the new pad and paper it was two steps
it was grab the grab the pen and write
down your email and we basically just
pushed the rest of the steps on austin
and myself to actually input it
and so that was how we got say
our first 2 500 to 5 000 subscribers and
then the next process became okay we've
saturated the michigan market
now what and then now what became how do
we find austin and alex at every other
college in america so how do we find
the the two people that are gonna
basically get in front of all the hubs
at other schools that aren't us and so
that's what led to our college
ambassador program and our college
ambassador program you know it still
exists to this day we learned so much
with it and i think it was unique at the
time because
i never heard of a media company doing a
college ambassador program when i think
of college ambassador programs i think
of like red bull uh college ambassador
or ambassador program where people park
the red bull car in front of a
university they have people with
backpacks that hand out red bulls but
never for a media company
and we ended up
going through many iterations where the
first ambassador program we went for the
quality approach we were where we were
like let's get the best ambassadors
across the country to represent morning
brew so we had this super uh rigorous
application process it was like harder
to get into our ambassador program than
to get into harvard uh or oxford it was
like we put out an application people
applied they dropped their resume we
ended up accepting i think 15
ambassadors who were like they were the
influencers in their business programs
at their schools they were in all of the
clubs they were the class president you
know they sat in the front of their
class
and it absolutely bummed our first
ambassador program did not work well
it didn't work well because
what we didn't account for is that while
all of these students that we accepted
were really impressive
people don't have a good
sense of time management when they're in
college like they really haven't figured
that out yet and so these students were
the people who are already so involved
on things in campus that they had they
actually were the people the least
amount of time and they had spread
themselves so thin that they could never
commit to our program so the second time
we did it we went exact opposite
approach we went with the quantity
approach where we fully automated the
process so we sent out an application
but everyone was accepted we just wanted
wanted it to have an error of
exclusivity so you'd fill out an
application you'd get an automated email
from us that you were one of a few
people accepted to this program and then
you'd get automated emails from us about
how to start sharing morning brew so
you'd get a google drive that included
marketing collateral a script for what
to say in classes sign up sheets that
you could print out to pass around
classes
only when you got to say i think it was
25 sign ups did you actually get put
into a group with austin and i where we
talked to you and so we had this vetting
system for big top of funnel
uh but only have human interaction with
students when they've kind of proven
that they can do well as an ambassador
and when we did that second program we
had 250 ambassadors across 200 schools
and so that was our focus uh kind of for
the rest of college was growth and
getting the content down that really
reminds me of the whole you know do
things that don't scale yep because you
know if i imagine like we we've just
launched a new a new newsletter for our
creatorpreneur brand you know trying to
help creators think more like
entrepreneurs the last thing on my mind
would be let me go out manually recruit
some ambassadors and get them to spread
the word for my email list it's just
it's so rogue it's so it's so analog in
the world that we live in today i gotta
be honest if i'm you i'm thinking about
how do i every time colin and samir post
a video how am i commenting with my
newsletter on their videos because
because the people watching their videos
are all creators
yeah
so
you're growing this newsletter
basically door-to-door uh but like at
scale um yeah what
what did the numbers look like in that
first year like 2015 when you were yeah
so when i graduated from michigan uh i
want to say we were at 10 000
subscribers oh so we got to 10 000 by
the end of senior year
but i had a decision to make because i
graduated from college and i had this
job to work in finance so i basically
had to make the decision am i going to
do this job that again was my dream for
my entire life like this was the peak
this was the pinnacle
or
was i going to quit my job
tell
my overprotective jewish mom that i was
gonna go do this newsletter thing that
makes no money uh that has ten thousand
people on it rather than doing the thing
that i dreamed of uh i did not do the
second uh i went and i worked at morgan
stanley sales and training
generally you start early in the day so
i would wake up at five a.m every day i
would i would go to the office i would
work out i'd be at the desk by 6 30 i'd
trade from 6 30 until
7 pm
7 pm i'd go back to my apartment and
basically from 8 p.m to
when i fell asleep with my laptop on my
lap i would work on morning brew and
that was effectively
my entire experience at morgan stanley
until i quit my job
how long did you do this before you quit
the job so i i started at
i graduate june of 2015 i go to new york
my job starts july of 2015 at morgan
stanley i quit my job september of 2016.
so just over a year it was right after
uh labor day of of 2016
and the reason i quit was
basically austin as i mentioned he's two
years younger and he had
had his junior year internship he got an
offer to work in investment banking and
he now had to make a decision basically
two years after me was he going to go
full time into investment baking or do
morning brew and i vividly remember
austin came to new york uh for a weekend
we got beers at this like really old bar
one of the oldest bars in new york city
we basically talked about like what are
we gonna do like there's a clear fork in
the road it was a fork in the road of
we're either gonna go full time on this
thing or we're not and if we don't go
full time on this thing like this is
it's either gonna
stop or it's gonna just be kind of like
a shell of itself because i was working
a lot austin investment banking i
remember during his internship he had
pulled like four all-nighters in his
summer of his internship and so it was
very much like this was an inflection
point and we decided to go full time on
it
and i i think we had different reasons
for going full time on it and for me
the reason i went full time
was a few fold i thought about things in
terms of regret
what would i regret more would i more
regret staying at morgan stanley
and seeing
someone create effectively their version
of morning brew and it succeeding or
would i more regret leaving morgan
stanley doing morning brew and morning
brew fails and i have to find a new job
and to me the answer was obviously when
i answered that question which is i
would far more regret staying at morgan
stanley and seeing someone succeed with
their version of morning brew just
because they
risked their time when when i wouldn't
that was the first way i thought about
it the second way i thought about it was
what is the worst case scenario so i
thought i always use things as like the
worst case scenario framework in a
decision and can you live with the worst
case scenario so the what what's the
worst case scenario if i quit my job and
went full-time on morning brew and the
worst case scenario was i quit my job i
work on morning brew and then say six
months later it fails because the vast
majority of businesses fail and then i
was like then what what would have
happened in that worst case scenario and
i said
first maybe morgan stanley would take me
back because i had this entrepreneurial
experience that made me
maybe maybe
unique in my experience
and uh they would value that and i would
say i said no let's say that's the worst
case scenario and i burned my bridges
and they wouldn't take me back then what
it was like maybe this makes a good
business school story where i could
apply to business school and i said you
know what maybe uh this is a common
story and it would get me into business
school and i said maybe
um i
met other people while i was doing this
startup in the startup scene and i could
go start another company or join an
early stage company and i basically got
like four or five layers deep of options
and i was like if none of these are
options
after morning brew fails
then this isn't actually like a morning
brew problem this is an alex problem of
not keeping his options open as a
professional and so that was the second
way i looked at it and the third way i
looked at it was simply about how do i
want to live my life it sounds cliche
but
i very much you know i just had like a
mentally transformative experience where
a week before junior year of college at
michigan uh my dad passed away suddenly
uh he passed away
uh from a stroke he was 49 years old he
was perfectly healthy like literally
built the same as me
similar uh physical health
and after that experience everything
just became clearer around
one how most things that we worry about
on a daily basis in life are wildly
unimportant
and two
how
really like you know your your time on
your uh life countdown clock you have no
idea when it's gonna hit zero you look
at the statistics and you hope that it's
gonna hit zero around you know 80 years
old or later but you really have no idea
and basically i said to myself if if i
knew my countdown clock was hitting zero
tomorrow what would i rather be doing
with my time and it was like a
no-brainer it was like i knew that i was
so
more so far more enjoying the experience
of building my own thing and tinkering
like i was tinkering in kindergarten
than sitting in front of a computer
screen and trading mortgages
wow
yeah i'm sorry to hear about your dad
that that must have been really tough
for you at the time
yeah it was uh
it was really tough for a few reasons
obviously it was it was shocking
it was
one of those things like he he was my
best friend and it was like you know he
was the guy that when i would uh be
walking from class uh back to home or
vice versa like he was the person i was
texting or calling and it was uh it was
a surreal thing like there was a period
of time after he passed away where i
would just be walking in new york city
and i would call his number just to
relive that experience
and it registers it's pretty funny thing
now for a while i'd call his number and
it would just you know go to like this
number is not in service because after
he passed away we didn't you know he
didn't keep his phone obviously and then
at probably six months to a year later
they reinstate phone numbers get
recycled and so i still do this to this
day
probably i do probably like once a year
now where i call his number
and there's a family who has his phone
number now
and it's just interesting to hear it's
been the same family for the last like
seven years
and uh they're probably like who is this
random 973 number that calls us once a
year says nothing and hangs up
um but yeah i mean so there was apps
there was a there was a huge void that i
felt because it really was my best
friend
and then i think the final thing is
it um it made me think a lot about just
like my emotions and how i process
emotions
because i think as a function of growing
up in a wall street family as a function
of you know being a man and there being
certain gender norms with being a man i
think as a function of my own coping
mechanisms i found like my
my best trick my best trick and my worst
trick was to take emotionally provoking
things and push them into my body and
not feel them and i'm really good at
that trick and i think that trick paid
dividends in my career as an
entrepreneur because i think as [ __ ] was
hitting the fan at different times
like i was cool as a cucumber i really
did not feel
like scared at any moment in our journey
even if it was completely rational to
feel scared but the reason i say that is
you know after my dad passed away i only
cried once and it was such an
interesting thing to me and that i felt
guilty about for a long time because i
was like this is probably the worst
thing that's gonna happen to me in my
life is a tragedy like this and i only
cried once like
how do i only cry once about losing my
best friend suddenly and so this is
something i still work on to this day
and think about to this day which is how
do i better
have access to my emotions because
they're absolutely there my body has
just buried them how do i have better
access to my emotions so i can
experience things fully and emotions
give you amazing data in life to know
what you love what you don't love what
you want to do and what you don't want
to do
wow i think thank you for being so open
about this yeah of course this is this
is something that i
have been thinking about as well
in the sense of yeah being an
uh sort of entrepreneur bro um
you know growing up in a asian family
meets kind of an old boys school meets
you know talking about and feeling
emotions and stuff very much frowned
upon yep uh
and then i discovered stoicism and i was
like yeah stoicism kool-aid like yeah
you know this is how i've been living
anyway i'm a stoic sage etc cetera i
don't feel
i don't feel negative emotions if i
don't want to i i'm also right now
trying to figure out
how
basically
it's going to sound kind of weird but
like how to feel more oh no this is what
i'm working on constantly
yeah how how are you doing it
uh well one this is like the focus
i would say there's two topics that i
generally focus all of my time with my
therapist on
one is
how do i feel more
but
i've changed the wording over time to be
like intentional with not how do i feel
more because i think that uh implies
like that i am feeling less right now
and i'm not feeling enough and there's
something wrong with me and i and so
what i've changed it to me is how can i
fully
feel my feelings so whatever my feelings
are whatever my emotions are how can i
get to a place where i am fully feeling
them
and nice and so
you know what we spend a lot of time
doing is
she will help me visualize like moments
in my life to try to
because what she's realized about me is
like i i'm a very visual person and so
like i get images whenever i think of
something and so for example you know i
shared with her in probably our second
or third session together that
i was uh bullied in school probably from
fifth grade to
the end of high school like i i was
bullied i never felt like i was a part
of a group like i always aspired to be
part of like the cool group in high
school i never felt a part of that group
i felt like i was always
trying to seek their approval but never
received that approval and so a lot of
times she'll actually have me visualize
that she'll be like what is a moment
that you felt really lonely and
felt really sad for yourself because you
didn't feel like you were belonging in
high school and i would describe a
moment i'd be like you know it was down
to the couches the senior couches in the
high school at the school i went to
i was sitting at the couches there were
like eight people there i would say
something people would dismiss it and
people literally like turn their bodies
to not include me in that discussion
and she would tell me to like close my
eyes and like sit with envisioning those
people talking and closing their bodies
to be me being on the outskirts and
she would say what comes up for you you
know what would your older self right
now if you were sitting next to your
17 year old self what would you say to
him as he's feeling really upset for
himself that he doesn't feel belonging
and so i think she's trying to leverage
what she knows that is intuitive and
natural to me which is visuals and put
me back in kind of this time machine of
life the other thing she tells me to do
is like to sit with
emotions when i feel them meaning like
any type of emotions like when i'm
laughing hysterically at something she's
like before you go on to the next thing
because your best trick is distraction
distraction through intellectualization
or doing something before you do either
of those before you intellectualize or
you distract
if you're laughing hysterically or if
you're annoyed with something that
a family member said or you're
pissed with your co-founder
just spend 30 seconds and just sit in it
like just sit in it don't have any
expectations of it but just sit in that
feeling because you're retraining
yourself to realize that you are in fact
feeling something and over time
it will become natural where you don't
have to get yourself for 30 seconds to
sit in that feeling have you found
working with a therapist useful
extremely useful
extremely useful i find it useful
because one i think in a force it forces
for me the accountability to reflect
which i think in the busyness of life i
will get out of the habit of doing and i
think it's really important i also think
again at the end of the day a therapist
is someone who has tools that they've
been taught in their career so like if i
wanted to figure out for myself how can
i feel my feelings fully
right i could go one way i could do it
is go read
many books on it and maybe get to that
answer or i could have an hour-long
session with someone who has read
probably all of those books also and
just can almost be like the summary of
those books but what i will say is i
think a therapist is kind of like
anything else in life where the they're
serving a purpose
to
help you tackle challenges that are
preventing you from being fully
filled up in life
and
different therapists have different
specialties and so what i mean by that
is there was a therapist who i worked
for
work so i worked with for probably this
first seven years that i was doing
therapy that was my first therapist and
she was amazing but i would say there
was a natural kind of like uh
deceleration of the learning curve or
the benefit curve where in the beginning
she gave me all of these tools for my
anxiety for my ocd and then it kind of
plateaued because i had those tools and
i found that we were talking about the
same thing over and over and what i
realized is for a long time i kind of
was just going through the motions of
doing therapy with this person because i
was like oh but this is therapy this is
what i do
and i think
what i only ended up doing later which
was important to reflect on is like
okay but it serves a purpose is it still
serving that purpose and what i realized
for myself is
this therapist had a specific set of
skills skills that helped uh with the
things i was working on at the time but
as i improved in those areas and i had
new challenges i want to work on maybe
my current therapist isn't the one who's
going to be most helpful in these new
challenges and so i ended up changing a
therapist to someone who i thought who
was for uh could be more helpful with
things like feeling my emotions or like
self-love and self-belief because it was
a therapist who her modality was things
like uh hokomi therapy which is about
feeling the body like it's very body
focused therapy and so that's a big
learning i had is like how easy our
brains can get into autopilot and just
assume what we're doing is the thing to
do if we don't question it
do you do these sessions of zoom or in
real life or i do it over zoom so my
therapist is based in colorado and we do
yeah we do these zoom meetings uh
usually every week or other week which
by the way this gets into another topic
like for the for a long long time
i felt very guilty about doing therapy a
lot because i'm very much like a money
hoarder and so i could i would get into
like i'd get anxious about spending
money on therapy i'd be like oh my god
this is a lot like you know my therapist
is uh 300 an hour i'm like this is a
[ __ ] ton of money like what do i really
need to spend on this and at some point
i got to the point where i was like if
if i am not willing to spend my money on
someone who is helping me see the world
more clearly and live a more fulfilled
life i do not deserve to have money that
i have because that is crazy to not
spend on something that is quite
literally making my life better um
and uh yeah so i talk to her every week
or other week um and it's it's really
good i will say
as someone who has a very creative and
distracted brain it is very easy for me
even as we're talking now for me to get
distracted with things on my computer
and so what i did now and i do with my
therapist is i literally close
everything the only application i have
open with her is zoom uh zoom and notes
because i'm i'm constantly writing down
notes as we're talking so i can reflect
on tools she's given me and also hold
myself accountable and her accountable
to like am i still getting value out of
this and so that's a big thing that i've
had to change with zoom because when i
was in person with my therapist like it
was harder to get distracted i tried a
therapist for like three or four weeks a
few months ago actually like last year
now that was ages ago
and i found that like i wasn't really a
fan like the first two or three sessions
was sort of helpful but then i did find
session four and five and six we were
sort of just sort of talking about the
same stuff
and part of me was thinking oh i don't
know if that's just the modality of zoom
just not being great for connecting with
someone in that way but it's it sounds
like you're getting a lot of value out
of this therapist through the zoom
sessions yeah and what i would say is
like i think therapy is in a lot of ways
like speed dating where i think it is
very reasonable to see like eight
therapists as a hypothetical number
before landing on one therapist because
it's almost like what are the odds that
you go on a first date with someone and
that person ends up being uh your
partner your life partner it's like the
odds are literally
it's like de minimis and so in the same
way like every therapist has a different
personality has different sets of tools
and you have very specific needs uh that
requires very specific tools and
personality in a way that lands with you
it's like to think the first person you
talk to is gonna be the right person is
like you're you know you're betting that
you're gonna win the lottery
yeah okay you're right i'm sold um i
will ask you for your therapist to email
the rest afterwards because that seems
good
a good first option cool um
yeah i guess i guess in my mind i was
thinking of therapists as kind of like
being doctors in that they are fungible
in that
one doctor at least here where we follow
guidelines is practically identical to
another doctor at the junior levels
anyway but i guess therapist yes i i
would argue that yeah therapists are
very non-fungible
excellent
that's your nft the non-fundable
therapist so you're at morgan stanley
for like a year and a bit where you're
working ridiculous hours and you're kind
of hustling to get this morning briefing
off the ground
this is a very common story amongst
basically all of the entrepreneurs you
and i know where in the early days of
the thing especially there is a level of
you know to use the that terminology
hustle and grind and
maybe losing a bit of sleep and maybe
not take fully fully taking care of your
health and really not prioritizing
things like self-care and a balanced
work life and these days it seems like
that sort of stuff is a bit like you
know there is a sort of anti-hustle
movement of like no
life should always be balanced at all
times and like self-care is really
important and stuff and no one would say
that that's not true but if you ask a
lot of entrepreneurs who've built
something from the ground up especially
in the early days they would have said
that no hang on in the early days i
needed to
de-prioritize self-care and stuff for
the sake of getting this thing off the
ground yeah so i wonder
with the benefit of hindsight um
do you think if you had had more of a
balanced life you and austin had more of
a balanced life you would have more than
that that morning brew could have been
as successful as it now is or how do you
think about that i think the answer is
no
i don't think morning brew would have
been as successful if we were more
balanced in our life as in spent less
time on morning brew but there's a big
caveat here that goes back to the idea
of uh guilt around procrastination i
think that it would have been possible
to have more balance and been a
successful morning brew
if i was more efficient
and smarter in my work and not a
procrastinator and i have not proven to
myself in life yet that i am capable of
that but if i can prove to myself that i
am capable of that i think it opens up a
lot more time for non-work things can
you tell me more about this
procrastination stuff like how yeah how
in particular i'm interested in the
early days where you've got a job and
you're doing this thing on the side
and now i you know we'll come to this
but i can imagine you're chilling
because you've got like because you're
stupidly rich and et cetera et cetera
but like you know in the in the early
days when you were you were hustling
what did the procrastination look like
i'd say there's two types of
procrastination it's doing non-work to
avoid work and it's doing the wrong work
to avoid work oh that's nice
and so doing non-work to avoid work is
where i would spend a lot of time on
social media and i would spend that time
on social media instead of
doing work and i would say actually
that's gotten worse over time
as i've created started creating content
on twitter and other platforms the
addiction to the dopamine hits of likes
and validation has gotten really bad bad
to the point where like i'm literally
thinking about do i want to create a
like an aaa for phone addiction the the
second type is work to avoid work and
what i mean by that is this goes back to
like how we're taught from a young age
uh and in school what it means to do
work and i think it means you're given
an assignment you do the assignment uh
you're given a test you take the test
you create checklists you do the things
on the checklist and there's a feeling
of that felt really good to do those
things on those checklists i feel like
i've achieved what i wanted to achieve
but the issue is is that as a startup
grows and it evolves the things that you
should be spending your time on change
and they look different
than the things that you were spending
your time on perhaps six months ago and
also the things that you felt really
good about doing and so here's an
example i mean there was a period of
time where i would spend hours a day
reaching out on linkedin to potential
uh advertisers of morning brew and i'd
do all this linkedin outreach to
hundreds of them then i would schedule
calls with them uh and i would do all of
this busy work related to outreach for
selling advertisers and it felt
productive because on my to-do list was
reach out to morning brew advertisers
schedule calls and morning brew
advertisers felt very productive and it
felt productive because the
justification in my head was
hey we need to make money as a business
through advertising this is time well
spent but as we were growing something
that became more important or became i'd
say a more important job
of me as the ceo of the business was
planning was thinking
okay where do we want the business to be
three months from now six months from
now 12 months from now and this was at a
time when we didn't have traction uh so
we didn't we didn't have the bible for
running a business
and so
what would happen would would be
what i just described to you of like
setting a strategy in the future so that
i know how i should be planning my time
today who we should be hiring today like
really important things i would never
spend time on it i would just never do
those things luckily i had a partner in
austin
where he was starting to think about
those things and he picked up the slack
there
but it was i was doing work that felt
good that i could justify was value
adding to the business to avoid the work
that really needed to be done to push
the business forward and so i would say
those are two types of procrastination
and for me what would end up happening
is
i've used this term before of like the
procrastination hangover and basically
it's the feeling of after a long day
feeling shitty like feeling this like
yucky feeling of like damn i just wasted
a day
i wasted a day
because
i wasted time doing things that don't
grow me for things that if i did them
they would grow me and i wasted time on
things that are easy tasks for me to do
because i didn't have the courage or the
focus to do those hard tasks and every
time that happens and i have a
procrastination hangover i think i lose
a little bit of trust and self-belief in
myself because i haven't kept my word to
myself of doing the things that are most
important to do and growing myself yeah
that makes so much sense i think a big
part of i think the emotional barriers
to procrastination i i find it it tends
to be two things it's either self-doubt
or it's fear i i think it's self-doubt
on two levels on one level it's
self-doubt of
i don't think i'm good enough to do this
thing
but on a deeper level it's i'm i'm not
the sort of person who does things i am
i am the sort of person who is a
procrastinator and you've got so these
these two levels of self-doubt and then
you've got the fear aspect of it which
is fear of not living up to certain
expectations for yourself or for others
or like fear of what people will think
and
you know that's why singing in public is
way harder than singing in the shower
because
you know
you've got you've got the fear component
michael my question for you is does that
kind of framing make sense with your
experience
yeah it totally does yeah
i think
it it makes me
because i have felt because i've
identified as a procrastinator for so
long
it's left me with kind of two
conflicting thoughts or feelings
on one side
it has made me lose self-belief in
myself
because it has made me feel like
whereas i want to believe that i am
capable of anything it has made me lose
belief that that is possible because i
haven't proven to myself that i can work
really hard and smart to make anything
happen it's also made me lose kind of
like belief and and
respect for myself because i feel like
to what you just said before i'm not
gonna realize my potential
because procrastination is keeping me
from doing it and while i know
it's quite simple what needs to be done
to not procrastinate which is to not
procrastinate
i have not shown an ability to do that
and so i don't know what is going to
change that and then on the flip side of
this so that is kind of like the the
negative kind of like self-loathing
version of this i've tried to have a
more productive thought about this to
say
procrastination is part of my way it is
part of my way of working
where as someone who is very creative
who has ideas all over the place who's
easily distracted
i can't i can't you know uh
i can't take one but not have the other
if i want to be someone who has an
abundance of ideas uh and who has all
these positive attributes from thinking
in the way i think i can't just expect
that i'm going to be someone who does
not procrastinate at all and is super
linear and focused and basically i've
that narrative is alex you have to
own the fact
that procrastination is part of your
process and it's okay and actually
like to say you won't reach your
potential uh is to say that you believe
that if you write yourself a
procrastination you wouldn't rid
yourself of all the other things that
make you great that make you possible of
your potential i don't know if i totally
buy that argument i think that's why
it's tough for me is i i try to as i'm
experiencing this turn it into a
positive where i'm not so down to myself
because i don't want to keep harming my
self-belief but i also don't buy that it
has to be a part of me i guess it sort
of
in a way is
can can kind of be a coping mechanism
for
dealing with the negative feeling it's
like oh the negative feeling is actually
positive so it's all good kind of stuff
yeah and i think it's um it's one of
those thoughts like it's like that
negative feeling isn't doing anything
for me anyway it's only holding me back
it's making me believe in myself less so
how do i get to myself where i believe
in myself more so at least that
you know it puts it puts me on a more
solid foundation to push forward in life
what what's your take on this
i i was doing a lot of it on the book
and
it was after having a session with
rachel who's our editor and also kind of
book writing coach having had loads of
experience with it
where we basically diagnosed that it was
self-doubt that was the main
cause there
where my standards were just too high i
was trying to produce stuff you know i
was comparing my shitty first draft to
james clare or mark manson or tim
ferriss's or dan pink's final draft yeah
and i was like oh you know this every
the the stuff i'm writing is just [ __ ]
and
realizing that like
loads of people have this thought as
well when starting youtube channels like
they see themselves on camera and
they're like oh my god like i can't i
can't string sentences together without
making mistakes etc etc but they're
comparing it to someone else's final
draft because you never see a non-edited
version of someone's video
and within our youtuber academy there
are some you know sometimes i would just
upload a completely unedited version of
one of my videos for people to see just
unlisted and they'd be like oh my god
this makes me feel so much better
because i realize that even a pro like
ali still has takes an hour to film a 20
minute video because of all the
stumbling and stuff that happens along
the way and now when it when it comes to
youtube the conversion from a shitty
first draft into a decent looking output
is something i'm very familiar with
having done it 500 times whereas in
writing the conversion of a crappy first
draft into a decent looking book is
something i'm not at all familiar with
having done it zero times yeah so it's
like i don't have that data or that
conviction to know that actually the
thing that i'm doing is good enough
whereas in youtube i know that we can
always fix it in post that's fine we'll
we'll we'll deal with it this podcast i
know i can just take a break turn the
air conditioning on get a coffee we'll
you know we'll fix it in post yeah i
didn't have that for writing after
diagnosing that it was self-doubt that
was the problem and basically you know
the solution to that is just lower your
bar lower the standards embrace
embrace the crap a little bit more
now i've actually found it pretty easy
to not procrastinate on on book stuff i
still procrastinate in the sense i'll go
and make a cup of tea i'll go and kind
of wander around a little bit but i kind
of know that okay my job for these next
few days is to bang out 6 000 words a
day for each first draft of the chapter
and it's and it's being done
so in that sense i don't procrastinate
but in but it was it was only that
little that mental flip of self-doubt is
the cause here that made it work for me
i have a question how did you and maybe
this is just how you're wired or
oriented like as you gained uh
subscribers on the youtube channel which
by the way congrats on three million uh
as
you were along this journey how did you
not feel the pull
to ultimately get sucked into
checking views on your videos in a way
that ultimately is procrastination from
doing work that would allow you to make
better videos
did you ever go through periods in kind
of your youtube career
of checking
views subscriber count watch time
obsessively or was that just never
really in your dna um yeah i've had
phases where i go through it and
it normally makes me feel quite bad to
go through it if the numbers are going
up then it's like ah crap the numbers
are going up
we're gonna we're gonna get into a down
slump soon and the numbers are going
down like they are right now it's like
oh crap we're in a down slump oh i don't
know i i think this might be the
beginning of the end what i've found is
that the the best way for me to overcome
this is to just and and everyone says
that it sounds so cliche but just to
dissociate my own self-worth from the
things that i cannot control as much as
possible
so now
i i think i've gotten better at this
over time just uploading a video
and
looking at the views and the numbers but
like really trying not to let them
affect anything because
my bar is now an internal thing that i
control which is
i will upload a video if i think it's
good or if i if i think it's a message
where it's worth sharing that would be
helpful to at least one person
and when i have that sort of zen
attitude towards it that's when a i feel
i make better content because now i'm
not concerned about oh my god what's the
audience gonna think a b i feel a lot
better about it that's what we're all
trying to achieve and again it sounds so
simple like oh you know don't don't
watch your v don't look your views don't
like your subscribers don't look at you
know how your channel is trending over
time just enjoy just feel good about
that you've gone through the process of
putting content you feel proud about it
into the world
it sounds so simple it's just uh it can
be very hard at times yeah i i think
this is where kind of intrinsic and
extrinsic motivation comes in where when
when for me the youtube channel was
purely a side hustle it's like oh i'll
make whatever videos i want because i
want to help people and it's all good
and maybe two or three people if they
sign up to my course it becomes
profitable whatever i don't really care
but now that the youtube channel is the
foundation of the whole business now
it's like oh [ __ ] like
you know the stakes are so much higher
at least in my mind what if this just
crumbles around me and everything dies
and end up broken homeless and alone and
i'm not worthy of love and all that all
of those geez that's a lot going back to
the therapist this is probably good
stuff
with them
all of that all of that kind of stuff
just comes comes to the forefront
yeah well i mean that's an interesting
thing you bring up right which is like
your youtube work has kind of moved from
play to job because it is yeah it's it's
your job in the sense that it is the
source of your livelihood and not not to
create obligation for you but livelihood
of other people also yes and so it's
like how do you feel the benefit of that
play when it is quite literally a job
yeah and honestly that's the thing oh
one one thing that um so i've i've got a
coach his name's corey he might have
seen on on twitter uh he
and i basically kind of brainstormed
solutions to this problem about two
weeks ago and actually i started using
affirmations
and this is surprisingly helpful um
i'm just going to read you out my
affirmations and yeah like just like
i don't i don't do this every day i
still need to make it part of my morning
routine
but oh well one thing i have found
helpful is for the last month or so i've
been doing journaling in the form of
morning pages every day
and often i will think to myself you
know am i am i feeling bad about some
performance of a video or something
and then i'll sort of
reverse engineer okay why am i feeling
bad i'm feeling bad because xyz yeah and
it will often come back to these
affirmations so these are yeah i want to
hear the affirmations yeah um so number
one
i already have enough i don't need more
money or success i am playing my
infinite game to learn and teach cool
stuff on my own terms
number two my life experience is
interesting and worthwhile people would
love to hear what i have to say about it
three i don't care about numbers i just
do my thing and my amazing team will
take care of the rest four if i lost
everything i'd be able to build back up
again to this infinite game over time
and it would be even more fun
five creative energy surges through me
and leads to new and brilliant ideas six
today i am brimming with energy and
overflowing with joy and then finally i
have been given endless talents which i
can use whenever i feel like it to
create value in the world
and all of these affirmations are just
sort of
tackling a negative thought process or a
negative belief about myself that no one
cares what i have to say i lucked into
this position and now it's going to come
crumbling around me at any time i really
have to try very very very hard to make
content that peop to make sure people
care about the content because
me just speaking from the heart is not
going to be interesting
and it's like all these
so someone from the outside would say no
you can make a video about whatever you
want you've got three million goddamn
subscribers just like don't worry about
it but like from the inside it feels
like oh no but like oh we it was so
lucky to get here right now it's just
gonna come crumbling down so i find that
affirmations genuinely i love that can
can you read the uh the fourth one again
that one really resonated with me i
wanted to read and i just want to react
to it because that one stood out to me
the fourth one if i lost everything i'd
be able to build back up to this
infinite game over time and it would
probably be even more fun both
so
that's that's the most provoking one for
me and the reason is is and i think this
loops back into procrastination i i
actually think at its core
procrastination is the source of me
feeling so provoked by this
and i think it's why
i have kind of like this money hoarding
mentality
because it almost feels like you know
with this business i did
this was my
one shot and my one luck at making money
because after this
because i'm a procrastinator i'm not
going to be able to achieve success and
so i need to hold on to whatever the
hell i have because for the remainder of
my
you know however many years on planet
earth
uh
i'm not going to be able to reaccumulate
right and so it's like such a sad thing
right that's like such a sad perspective
that basically like i i've quote-unquote
peaked and i'm not gonna do anything of
worth or value in life moving forward
because i procrastinate and so i've
proven to myself that i can't be a good
diligent worker that can push through
any challenge
and i think that's why the fourth one
stands out to me so much and i think
it's why
i'm so focused on things like not
spending on a therapist
nice
yeah
that's good so
you quit the job a year down a year down
the line you at austin went on it full
time i want to kind of fast forward to
when
when the sale happened because i'm
curious about like money and that kind
of stuff and i know we're skipping up a
lot of a lot of the ground midway
through but i imagine people can find
the story on the internet if they want
to learn more well what was the story
behind selling morning brew we we sold
the business in october of 2020 to um
business insider's parent company which
is axel springer large media company
based out of berlin germany
and
that was a conversation that had
basically been
a year in the making in november of 2019
we had been approached by
uh this guy who uh
now works at one of the uh at one of
axel springer's um european media
businesses but at the time he was a
senior person at
uh business insider and we had become
friendly the the reason we reached out
is we we'd become friendly so basically
to give context on why we had become
friendly as i would you know i was just
hustling to grow morning brew one of the
growth tactics that i thought about is
let me reach out to big business
publications who are always looking for
more content to drive website uh traffic
and let me see if they would syndicate
our newsletters on their website uh and
so i reached out to one of the editors
at business insider saying hey would you
syndicate all of morningbird's
newsletters so every day you basically
have an extra article that you can put
out that you didn't have to write you
didn't have to pay to have it written
and can you just have a call to action
at the end to sign up for morningbrew
and so for us the benefit is
hypothetically a lot of traffic to drive
subscribers and i'd asked him a ton of
times it clearly wasn't a priority i
reached out to him probably like the
10th time and he was like i don't want
to deal with you anymore let me
introduce you to this guy so he
introduced me to the guy that i was
referring to before who ultimately kind
of became the champion of this deal and
uh this guy and myself we became uh
friends we got beers on stone street in
new york city which is this street it's
kind of like this alleyway with a bunch
of bars in the financial district of new
york city it's a great spot to go to
next time you visit new york um we would
go back and forth playing ping pong at
our different offices so i'd go to
business insider's offices play
ping-pong there he would come to our we
work space which we were in at the time
play pong
he reaches out in in uh november of 2019
and is basically like hey
business insider is looking to do more
kind of
the the phrase to get people into
acquisitions if you want to test it is
not hey would you be interested being
acquired it's like we're interested in
deep partnerships would you be
interested in a deep partnership
and
and i was like uh do you mean acquiring
morning brew and he's like yeah it's
something we'd be interested in viewer
and
up to that point austin and i had not
thought at all about selling the
business uh we had been approached a few
times uh but we really weren't
interested what i always said is
everything that i wanted at the time is
what i had we got to be in charge of our
own destiny
i was learning and growing a lot was
surrounded by amazing team didn't have
to worry about money i was putting like
creating something valuable in the world
if those five things weren't being
messed up why would i change it
ultimately he was like well what's a
price at which you would be
interested in having a conversation and
i'd said uh 50 million dollars and so
you know this person was like well
that's something that would be in you
know the the sphere of what we would be
open to so let's have a conversation and
so we started having
a conversation basically deal terms were
put in front of us in february of 2020.
okay
just a question on that front when you
throw out 50 million and he's like yeah
we can work with that like don't you
just like crap your pants like
what's going on in your mind i i if i
remember correctly at that time austin
and i were like holy [ __ ] that's a lot
of money we should probably have this
conversation like that's that's enough
money but basically we were always like
what's a stupid amount of money that
it'd be worth having a conversation
about a stupid amount of money that was
our thing so like austin we're like yeah
we should probably have this
conversation so then we're having our
conversation typically the way that a
deal goes down is we had a banker so we
had a banker who he hired this banker
was the person who interfaced with
insider uh an axel springer because
normally what you the reason one of the
reasons you are banker is like if you
have austin and i interfacing with them
and a deal like it gets to be a very
like tough negotiation and an emotional
negotiation kind of ends up awkward when
you end up closing the deal and you're
like yeah all those things that we
yelled at each other about let's just
forget about those so baker kind of acts
as like
the intermediary so the relationship
doesn't get hurt in any way the banker
also was the person who managed our data
room so all of our financials and
information about the business that's
what insider an actual springer would
look like to come up with what they
thought the terms of the deal should be
and that this is kind of how any
acquisition process happens
and so ultimately they put terms in
front of us in february of 2020. the
terms we thought
looked good and reasonable at the at the
time like we're like okay this is a
really good deal the reason the deal
ended up getting extended is
march of 2020 is when the pandemic
started and so when the pandemic started
our business for a period of kind of
like three weeks got absolutely crushed
so there was a period of three weeks
where we thought our advertising was
going to be going was going to go down
by 50 percent we were getting call after
call from brand saying hey we don't know
what's happening in the world we are
pulling back all of our marketing and so
during that time period it was really
going back to the early days of morning
brew where it was just straight up
survival mode
finally in you know called april
our business normalized things were back
they were strong
and
uh at that then at that point like you
know uh our insider like i think uh they
were had things going on they were
working on things so really it took a
year to do this deal
we ended up closing the deal finally
in october of 2020 and you know i'll
always remember exactly where i was
uh i was in my mom's place in new jersey
i was with my mom i was with my
girlfriend at the time now fiance they
had
bought uh champagne they had bought
balloons and we have basically there's a
final call where like the deal has
already been finalized all the documents
have been signed and in a deal process
like this the number the number of pages
of documentation it like the the final
kind of like document book the deal book
was probably i can't remember the exact
number i think it was 400 pages
um
the documents were signed and we all get
on a zoom
austin myself and all the parties from
uh axel springer and insider that were
very involved in the process
and
then basically on the call is when
someone from axel springer is like okay
we're starting the wiring process yeah
and they're like that's basically them
saying we're hitting up uh axel
springer's bank right now to wire
you austin and any other equity holders
in the business their money for what
we're paying for the business
and what i remember in that moment going
back to talking about feelings is i felt
nothing
nice
i felt i felt nothing my fiance
my mom were super happy for me
you know they they wanted me to pop
champagne like they were they were they
understandably and rationally they were
so happy for me
but it was like i don't know i didn't
feel
anything
and i think i didn't feel anything
because
one nothing in that moment changed about
what i was doing on the business the
thing that did change like the objective
thing that changed
was that we now had a new partner who
thankfully was you know saying that like
we could run the business as we wanted
to which is what they've allowed us to
do and the only other thing that changed
was obviously
you know a few more zeros in the bank
account
and
i didn't feel anything about that
because
uh something i had just known about
myself i wasn't really going to change
my habits
and to this point that really has been
the case like
if you were to ask me what have i spent
on
since being acquired and coming into
more money than i could have imagined
there's nothing in my life that i've
spent on that i wouldn't have spent on
prior um
you know you know maybe i'm spending a
few more dollars to a trip that i'm
taking this summer with my fiance than i
would have we bought a dog i would have
bought a dog otherwise
and also i think the other part of it is
going up to that point we knew the
business was valuable we knew that our
equity was valuable and so we knew kind
of as long as we didn't [ __ ] things up
we would make money at some point but
yeah that was the kind of interesting
thing is i didn't feel anything and you
know just to kind of kind of complete
the feeling around the money here you
know as we're talking a year and a half
now after the acquisition i would say i
am
no more happy in life
today than i was before we did the deal
and i had less money i would actually
argue
that i probably met the same happiness
today and for a while
i was less happy because i was less
happy for a few reasons one is because i
knew money
could no longer be a motivator it could
no longer be a crutch for doing things
and so i think in a lot of ways i had to
refine like what is go what is going to
motivate me moving forward in april of
2021
i moved out of the ceo role into the
executive chairman rollup morning brew
so that's five months after the deal
and i think for the first six months of
being in that new role
my happiness absolutely went down
because i was like wow
this whole business
has been my identity for my entire
professional life
like
people know me quote-unquote know me as
alex from morning brew
i as the executive chairman now who now
is spending say 30 hours on the business
out of 80 hours i'm getting one step
further from the business to start
tasting what it's like to not be a part
of this business at some point and what
i realized in that moment is no amount
of money can
help me in that feeling of feeling a
loss of identity of not knowing what
motivates me and trying to figure out
what is it going to be that's my north
star pushing me forward it sounds like
in well since you started morning brew
and kind of grew it to the point that i
got acquired you're
in a way
you don't need to answer the question of
what am i doing here what is my purpose
because you have a very nicely packaged
purpose in morningbrew.com
and
watching numbers go up and employees
being kept happy and advertisers being
kept happy and the product being made
better and better is
in a way such an all-consuming thing
that
you really it really doesn't give you
much space to sit down and think huh
wha what do i really want to do here i
think like i was chatting to my brother
about this so he's in you know they're
in early early stage startup mode series
a where he's spending all day on sales
calls because they haven't yet figured
out the sales yep you know i was asking
him like how how do you feel about this
this was uh
maybe about six months ago he was like
yeah you know it doesn't feel great
but it's like my baby and like once you
have a baby like you've just gotta you
know feed the baby like yeah it's it's
not even a choice it's it's not even a
thought that would cross his mind and he
was asking me you know why do you still
do the youtube channel where because
where some of the time it feels like a
slog totally like honestly it's it
wouldn't it would never cross my mind to
not be doing the youtube channel
but
if suddenly someone offered me 100
million to sell my youtube channel then
it would be like
okay
would you do it
i don't know i probably i probably would
um as long as there was and
and and the reason i would is because i
think over over time i've
tried to basically
create this almost meditation for myself
guided meditation where it's like close
your eyes
visualize yourself in like the nicest
apartment you can imagine like hanging
out with the girl and like you know
chilling your friends are around you've
got 100 million in the bank you don't
need to worry about money mate like
what are you gonna do tomorrow like how
are you actually spending your time yep
and i kind of realized that
basically the stuff that i'm doing right
now i.e making videos writing a book and
recording podcasts once in a while is
broadly the stuff i would be doing i
probably won't bother making more
courses like that's the only bit of the
business that we do for the extrinsic
reason of that well it helps fund the
business but if for example someone were
to come around along and say hey you
guys never need to worry about money
ever again we will fund you forever
we would just put all of our courses
completely free online yeah everyone to
access so that's the only real
difference there
and then that made me feel good because
it helped me realize that for me my
north star thing is like
i just want to learn have the freedom to
learn stuff and teach stuff on my own
terms
and whenever i feel uh the number
anxiety around oh numbers aren't going
up as much as i'd like
i come back to that thing of like no but
even if i had 100 million in the bank i
would still be doing this thing so why
don't i just act as if that's true right
now why don't i just act as if i don't
need to worry about money and just make
them make the content that i want
because i think it's interesting and
valuable and also the money will take
care of itself coming back to
affirmation number two which is which is
basically that
um yeah how was that for you i i think
that was good um and i think it's a
beautiful thing again that this stuff
you're spending your time on is the
stuff that you would spend your time on
even if you never had to worry about a
dollar again you know other than
uh the course and monetizing the course
one thing i'm wondering and
i don't know if you've thought about
this and maybe it's just like such a
basic emotion that you feel that's hard
to describe how do you know you're
enjoying writing a book or how do you
know
that you're enjoying that you enjoy
writing scripts and recording youtube
videos like how do you know that it's
something that fills you up uh one is
looking through my calendar at previous
weeks and asking myself did this thing
energize me or did this thing drain me
and generally for writing and for
talking to a camera and for doing
podcasts those are the things that
energize me and kind of working with a
team to brainstorm ideas most other
things generally admin related generally
operations related generally
spread of cell to advertisers related
completely drained me so i don't bother
doing them anymore so that's nice
another thing is that i often think you
know what would i want written on my
gravestone what i want people to say at
my funeral and other than kind of good
father good husband kind of vibes the
third thing that i really value is being
an
inspirational teacher to other people
um to kind of to sort of help them
basically help people live their best
life which sounds super cliche but i
think that is a thing that i can imagine
that if i could do that and i'm kind of
doing doing that at the moment so if i
could just continue doing that that that
to me feels like a life well lived and
then i've tried this exercise called the
ideal ordinary week which is you fast
forward in your google calendar like
five years get rid of all the recurring
events that are still there and then you
basically block out what are um
what do you wanna be doing and for me
it's like oh you know i'd like to play
squash twice a week i'd like to do board
games and i host friends etc etc and i'd
like to have this sort of four hour
block of deep work or whatever each day
where i can read and write and learn
cool things and share share ideas
almost almost broadly the schedule that
ryan holliday has where he just you know
from 9am till 1pm he'll just go to his
little room live with books all around
him and just read and write and then
he'll hang out with the family for the
rest of the day so i really like that
model of like this four hour work day
where the work that i'm doing is
basically around teaching other people
cool stuff and learning new things
myself so that is my kind of rough first
draft hypothesis of
this is the life i think i would enjoy
and i'm kind of close enough to it that
i get that real-time feedback of after a
session of book writing like this
morning i did like two hours of just
non-stop typing on the book and at the
end of it i was like yeah that was good
that felt fun uh similarly this podcast
right now i'm feeling like yeah this is
sick and afterwards i'm gonna think oh i
had an amazing conversation with alex
that was so fun so it's like i'm i'm
looking up for those sorts of feelings
that i get yeah so it's an interesting
thing because as much as you say you're
like trying to feel more you do have an
awareness of after you spend your time
on certain things just like generally
like
sitting in that moment like how do you
how does that feel to you like do you
feel like even like do you feel more
tired do you feel lethargic or do you
feel like you're you've been woken up or
like do you feel like your body's opened
or closed like it seems like you
actually have a sense of that and you do
that without kind of like you know
labeling it as like a tool or an
exercise yeah i think so i think i have
a pretty strong idea of that and i i
think also another thing that i i just
always ask myself just this question of
like would i do this for free and when
it comes to things like playing squash
or badminton or tennis that doesn't even
cross my mind because obviously the
answer is yes
but it's when money becomes the
extrinsic factor that it crowds out
intrinsic motivation right because it
becomes blurred and you don't know how
much each one is contributing to it
yes yeah exactly and so when i when i
was dabbling for a few months and being
a part-time doctor doing kind of shift
in the emergency department here and
there the thing i was finding myself
doing is every half an hour as i was
typing stuff on the computer and just
feeling a bit like i'm on the phone to
radiology and they're not replying and i
have to sit here for the next five
minutes waiting for someone to take my
call
would i do this would i really do this
if i won the lottery and i didn't have
to worry about money
the answer was like probably not like i
would much rather be in the studio with
my team thinking what cool youtube video
we can make to share a concept from
psychology
being here on the phone to radiology so
it was i i think that question is a
thing i often think about i think that
makes sense and and to make it a little
bit harder what i found to be difficult
was how did i know when something didn't
give me energy
versus when something was hard and i was
making an excuse for not being good at
the hard thing or wanting to work on the
hard thing and so the example i'll use
here is like
the op like the the parts of the
business that you know are austin super
powers uh for when we were you know
working hand in hand together so things
like
planning things like uh hiring road map
things like uh
even running like the traction process
like
those were things that
i didn't feel like i loved doing but i
was trying to distinguish do i not love
doing these things because they're
harder to me and things that come harder
to me because it's harder i don't love
doing it because it's harder and so
that's actually an excuse and that's a
good reason to do the thing to prove
that i can do something hard or is it
because i just really don't love the
thing because i like doing something
that's like more creative in nature or
interactive in nature or something
that's earlier in the process of
building something from scratch and so
for me
i would say that added another kind of
like access or variable it was like i'm
always thinking in my head on this
spectrum from 100 intrinsically
motivated to 100 extrinsically validated
or extrinsically motivated where am i
living on this and do i feel like it is
at a place on the scale that feels like
it's in check and it's a good reason to
do the thing and then the second one was
outside of the the money versus
intrinsic thing
am i do i
is something that i'm not doing because
i don't feel quote unquote good energy
from it is it because i actually don't
like it or is it because it's hard and
this is a good excuse to not do the hard
thing nice
so you've got your intrinsic extrinsic
access and you have your hard easy
access exactly
nice and you can use that in the book if
you want nice thank you
and and i guess your concern is that am
i like let's say you're doing something
that's 100
intrinsic
but also 100 easy you'd be like oh [ __ ]
wait a minute
is this really intrinsic or is it just
because it's easy that i'm enjoying this
exact exactly you know when you're at
this point where you've got extra zeros
in your bank account and you don't know
what to do with them and you're like
[ __ ] what do i what do i do with my life
yeah how did you go about finding that
north star is yeah how did you think
about that well if i'm being honest i'm
still in the process i still don't
really know what i want to be when i
grow up i know there are some options uh
like one option is to
build more businesses
like to go back to kind of the earliest
stage and
put cool [ __ ] into the world the second
is
to
help others become great entrepreneurs
because i do think
i love the energy of early stage
entrepreneurs uh you know
i've seen the impact that
entrepreneurship can have on a country
on an economy on a group of people and
to me that's really profound
so that's one thing a third thing that
i've considered which is totally out of
left field is to
become a therapist myself is like
literally to go get a psychology degree
become a therapist the the kind of like
business or startup variant of that is
to become an executive coach to coach
entrepreneurs uh
and so what am i doing today
well one it's like the time i spend on
morning brew is like creating content
finding creators to launch shows at
morning brew and dealing with the
biggest hairiest problems with austin
and the le the the lens that i look
through this is like how do i just learn
as much as possible in this experience
at morning brew right now because i'm in
a really privileged
point in the business where we have 275
people i have access to all these people
we're building something really cool how
do i just soak this all up for learning
uh that can selfishly help me in
building businesses in the future and
then outside of that right now i'm
basically spending time angel investing
and seeing kind of how it lands with me
to angel invest versus coach people so
i've started to coach a few people uh
and and for me again it's not really for
money it's just like do am i enjoying
coaching and also part of it it's like
can i prove to myself that i actually
can add value to entrepreneurs and like
push back on this imposter syndrome
and then the third thing
that i
candidly want to spend more time on is
like really focusing on on
not optimizing health because i
sometimes i feel like optimizing is
actually a bad word like i feel like it
creates actually a lot a lack of balance
uh and to me everything is good in not
everything but most things are good in
moderation and optimization sometimes
doesn't allow for moderation
but there are things like working on my
food intake my sleep like things that
generally just give me the best energy
in life and those are things that i want
to spend time on uh that i haven't yet
spent nearly enough time on and so to
answer your question i am
very scared
about
not knowing at the age of 28 what i want
to do
for the for many years
but i'm optimistic that if i'm patient
and if i'm both patient and inpatient
patient macro impatient and like feeling
like i'm not moving fast enough to
answer this question then i'll get to a
play like that i am where i'm supposed
to be and
that uh things will work themselves out
alex thank you so much this has been
absolutely wonderful uh where can people
find out more about you and we'll have
links to all of the stuff obviously in
the video description of the show notes
as well yeah first of all thank you so
much for having me i'm very excited for
when you finish your book and i can add
it to uh my reading list and my
bookshelf as well you can follow me uh
at business barista on twitter
uh and
you can check out my two podcasts
founders journal which is my startup
show about lessons from the
entrepreneurial journey and imposters
where i talk to
world-class performers from ray dalio to
jay shetty about
their careers and how they were able to
excel in their career careers even in
the face of really deep challenges and
uh the mental health journey that went
along with those challenges amazing
stuff alex thank you so much for coming
on everyone thanks so much for having me
you next time
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye